that time you put c4 in just the right
spot and blew it when your teammates
shouted there on the stairs that time
you rappelled down the edifice of a
building and cleared out a defender from
a window upside down that time your plan
sucked in terrorist hunt and the last
thing you heard was the wheezy gasp of a
bomber just before half your team was
incinerated or that time a youtuber shot
the hostage in the face at the end of
round five just when you were about to
win oh my god he did it oh my god he
shut off the face what a monster The
Rainbow six siege beta that we previewed
last week was made up of these moments
siege is a tough tactical game with
Wiley AI and even while air human
opponents we're careful communicating
teams must plan execute and adapt or
pretty much get their asses handed to
them what we saw in this build of siege
were new operators attackers blitz IQ
and fuse and defenders doc bandit and
jager notes some people have already
seen doc two new maps consulate and
hereford base hosted rounds of TDM bomb
TDM hostage TDM secure area and PvE
disarm bomb and terrorist hunt classic
yes devs have dropped the taro hunt
slang probably because they were getting
too many tarot card SEO hits my overall
impression of the new operators were
that many of their gadgets aren't is
useful as the original roster and PvP
but rather seemed designed for the new
PvE modes for example jaegers active
defense device that stops incoming
grenades would actually hurt you in PvP
we're getting the enemy team to frag the
hostage is a legit winning strategy but
in the PvE disarm bomb mode where waves
of enemy AI breach room you're defending
could be the key to stopping enemy
grenades from overwhelming your fire
team my favorite new operator ended up
being blitz who's flash shield is
essentially an on-demand flashbang
grenade akin to how sledge has a
permanent breaching ability with his
hammer when it comes two modes Vegas
fans asked and ubi delivered with
terrorist hunt classic unlike disarm
bomb the new PvE mode has no side
objectives and teams go fold America on
a build
full of white masks bad guys it was this
mode that the enemy AI showed their
prowess by free roaming the map even
flanking outside the building to pick
off repelling operators
shuffle up that's job nice job when it
came to gunplay the weapons of siege
still feel a little too friendly for a
tactical shooter the ability of those
carrying shields to rapidly hit by our
pistols in particular felt wrong
shotguns on the other hand where the
stand out of this build by not falling
victim to the typical video game trope
and delivering stopping power at decent
range as a shotgun should not to mention
punching sweet peekaboo holes in walls
siege still needs to balance weapons a
little to discourage run-and-gun tactics
that could ruin its tactical aspects
that's what a beta is for our team coach
kept choosing IQ solely for her weapons
and at the end of the three-hour session
despite having wiped out the opposing
team several times by herself hadn't
cracked her electronics detector gadget
at the end of the day I had a great time
with the siege beta there's nothing
quite like coming up with a plan on the
fly and getting all the moving parts to
work each round felt like a small game
of shooter chess the catch is that
communication relies largely on people
talking a new evolved style spotting
mechanic great directional sound and the
ability for dead friendlies to use
surveillance cameras to spot enemies
have all reduced the need for chatting
but any team that's talking will
probably win talking and planning with a
team is both sieges greatest strength
and potentially greatest weakness I for
one will not be reaching for the usual
mute all button that is necessary to
tolerate playing so many other
multiplayer shooters we'll see what the
casual game is like when the beta drops
on sep tember 24th for ongoing coverage
of Rainbow six siege stay tuned to
gamespot com keep quiet de la secured
extraction successful good work